good luck i hope you win bye
oh what a cutie princess charlotte is
embracing the spotlight with her daddy
prince william on sunday the
seven-year-old joined him in a new video
posted on the official social media
accounts for the duke and duchess of
cambridge
in the clip william has charlotte
sitting on his lap as they both wish
england's women's soccer team the
lionesses good luck ahead of the women's
euro 2022 championship
we both want to wish the lionesses the
best of luck for tonight you've done
amazingly well in the competition and
we're rooting for you all the way
good luck i hope you win bye
clearly charlotte is the spitting image
of her father and her mom kate middleton
as her long brown hair flows down her
blue polka dot dress
the post was captioned quote good luck
tonight lionesses we're all cheering for
you
good luck i hope you win bye
this is the first time that the young
royal has appeared to speak on her
parents social media page
missing from the video was kate and
william's other children prince louis
and prince george
lately the couple has been giving the
world a closer look at their children as
they continue to grow up and we are
definitely seeing their personalities
stand out prince george had his time to
shine last week when william and kate
shared an official portrait taken by the
duchess to their social media page in
honor of his 9th birthday and earlier
this month george's love for sports was
on full display as he made his debut at
wimbledon alongside his mother and
father plus who can forget this moment
when charlotte was caught correcting her
brother prince george's posture on the
palace balcony as the queen's platinum
jubilee celebrations came to a close
during the ceremony they played the
national anthem god save the queen
and george made the mistake of putting
his hand on the balcony's ledge
that's when his little sister nudged his
arm seemingly telling him to fix his
posture
[Music]
someone whose personality was also front
and center during the platinum jubilee
celebrations was george and charlotte's
little brother prince louis the
four-year-old made headlines for a
number of cheeky moments that et's royal
expert katie nichol was there to witness
on the palace balcony william and kate's
son louis adorably covered his ears and
started yelling as the military jets in
a seventy formation flew overhead the
four-year-old had the best facial
expressions as he waved wildly to the
crowd and chatted to his
great-grandmother the queen
his antics had his sister charlotte
actually scolding him at one point
telling him to pay attention
[Music]